[Music]
lifeline is an advice show for
entertainment purposes only if you need
real help or advice please seek a
therapist or a licensed professional
[Music]
welcome to lifeline we got a special
guest today look at him he's right there
on the table those of you might know him
as butter look at that fool butter's my
dog
a lot of people are you know a lot of
people are like do you still have your
dogs why did i ask you that because i
have a son now and i post pictures of
him that's that takes up all the cues
dude i don't like that when people have
kids or something like who cares about
the dogs no i don't it's not who cares
about the dogs no you said that i heard
you say it i don't think i said that you
said who couldn't come here dogs butters
don't do it you have your whole life
come on come here budders come on um but
i don't i don't uh i don't not like my
dogs now i just love having
chilling on the very end
you can't see him right now he's on the
very end so camera shy wow he's gonna
chill right there yeah um that's cool
man i brought my dog with me this time
um well one of them now why'd you only
bring the one we want to know i have
four it's too many one of them's too big
can't bring him i mean i guess i could
if i i just one seemed fine and he's
also pretty chill he's the one that's
gonna not bark too if somebody walks by
the door oh yeah he's the second most
chill cooper's the most chill cooper's
the most chill and then there's butters
that's not so chill and then there's sam
and uh chenzo that are just nacho
chenzo is just a [ __ ]
shooting star
he's his own man he does whatever the
[ __ ] he wants he doesn't care about any
kind of reprimands he's just going to do
it again do it again i'll he'll go right
right and i'll say quiet and then he'll
go
and then he'll go
yeah right yeah i mean get one little
[ __ ] it's like the dude that's just
like all right well fine okay then you
know what i mean you're like you dude
it's over already he had to get the last
word in yeah don't don't say one more
word and the guy's like okay yeah and
you're like oh okay
i wasn't gonna yeah yeah i wasn't even
gonna say that's okay
dude
uh speaking of dogs before we even go
though i got my goddamn oh yeah it's a
good reason yeah move mentality uh
hoodie on you can get it over at uh
lifeline um what is it
my lifeline merch.com or you can go to
my website chrislea.com and uh make sure
that uh you get that going so uh you get
your hoodies and spin move mentality
check that out yeah spin around and
check the spin move out that's what you
do that's why you do spin move and then
you turn around and they say why did
this guy oh
mentality and that's just the one of the
[ __ ]
you know that's the way we we live here
at lifeline yeah that's that's true uh
are you done though because i wanna had
something to say i'm gonna be in uh
atlanta and washington dc and savannah
georgia coming up so get tickets at
crystallia.com and yes go ahead well the
face you put on when you did that lick
your walter [ __ ] cronkite
and i'll be in atlanta and washington dc
savannah georgia and also peoria
illinois uh those are my two cents
crystallia.com
so speaking of [ __ ] dogs
i love my dog my dog's charlie a lot of
you learning english my dog is charlie
a lot of you might know that no but uh
every once in a while she sleeps on the
bed because she's a [ __ ] queen and
every once in a while rarely but every
once in a while she'll jump off the bed
in the middle of night what that means
is she gotta do it
or
vomi vomiville okay vomit villa root to
tooty dookie yeah okay and so under all
circumstances i want her out her out of
the house yeah she knows that but last
night it was so bad she was just
i couldn't get up fast enough i was so
out of it and she was just like running
around the whole house and i was like
what [ __ ] is she she's not the front
door oh right so i [ __ ] i'm i'm out
of bed i'm so out of it like i said i
had to [ __ ] i don't have my glasses
on i don't have my phone for like a
[ __ ] flashlight it's three four am i
don't even know and i'm just like all
right i'm gonna open the front door
let her out front and she'll just [ __ ]
or vomit right out front okay because
she's not the kind of dog that runs away
she'll wait for me okay you know
so i opened the door
and she's never moved faster what she
runs out the front door dude maybe she
had a dream so she runs out the front
door and i'm like [ __ ] i need to get my
glasses i need to get my glasses and i
don't have a [ __ ] my phone for a
flashlight so i run back in get my
glasses
get my phone for a flashlight
no [ __ ] charlie out front
there's just she's gone there's no dog
out front
what am i and at this point like where
my dog's at where am i where's my dog at
right yeah don't you don't need to
correct me
i did i did at this point like
where's my dog so
she's not there she doesn't have her
collar on i can't hear her anyway she's
not [ __ ] there dude and you're like
but you're like where my dog's at but
you're also like who let the dogs out
right well i knew who that you knew who
let the dogs out but anyway so i wasn't
asking so two dogs that wasn't my line
of inquiry my line in the information
was my dog
[Laughter]
where the [ __ ] is charlie so i'm looking
up and down the block nothing dude what
i'm like holy [ __ ] and i'm like am i
having a [ __ ] nightmare yeah
sometimes i have really real nightmares
it was the only time in my life i did
that thing where like people were like i
had to pinch myself right right i really
had to like wonder like what the [ __ ]
going on what the [ __ ] you're doing
what's up dude and uh dude
i run i'm like holy [ __ ] now i'm
panicking right yeah so i get panicked i
have no shoes on i run down the backyard
yeah there's a ton of dirt like are you
being submitted so
you know because i didn't have shoes on
and she's not in the back either then i
come back to the front she's not in the
[ __ ] front and then i'm like dude i
see coyotes all the time she was eaten
by a coyote the last thing i ever saw
exactly that was the only thing i could
think of like i would have heard the
chaos
so finally i'm going to run back in now
let's get my car keys to drive around
jesus and as i'm at the front door i
hear her little
tip tap on the concrete outside the
hedges of my house she had run up to the
bottom of the hill where the coyotes
basically live
taking a big fat dookie dookie kukaruki
and [ __ ] just [ __ ] it up i saw it
this morning it was like a trail of [ __ ]
and uh and that's my story dude you're
just like well that's crazy your dog
literally woke up and was like [ __ ]
these coyotes and where they live yeah
i'm gonna [ __ ] all over their open door
it was running it was like born free and
then [ __ ] goes up there takes a look
up the hill and just goes
yeah dude and then goes
yeah and y'all needed to do it at like
three in the [ __ ] a.m anyway i'm
happy i got my [ __ ] box from god
bless whoever hating on me they gave me
a t-shirt too they got me this hat and
then i got the old hat of course because
i came prepared for the thing enough uh
what the thing on the inside i think you
still have okay well i wanted it why do
you want the thing in it it makes it
more boxy i didn't oh you had the thing
the cardboard i didn't want it okay but
you said you i meant to do it but i
would show everyone okay
anyway look how [ __ ]
way better like that i've been pimping i
am can i see what it looks like on me
yeah
good day sir
[Laughter]
well your heads are the same size yay
well look at it in hash that's that's
the question do you look good in hats no
wow i looked over and chris marco was
going like this
so don't look good nobody knows but it's
and but it's okay dude whatever i don't
need hats you know why why's that
because i don't need to cover the top of
my head because i'm not jewish
well only for jews religiously you don't
need to come you're jewish that's the
thing well that has nothing to do with
anything uh our grandmother was maybe
jewish she was adopted we don't know and
we'll never know so here we go dude
we're going to be going on to the um
like we're going to be doing a lifeline
show right now i mean uh you did your
show we're going to be doing lifelines
we don't know if our grandma's jewish or
not because she was adopted we think uh
the facts are still out there and we'll
never know jesus religion but anyway
keep going what's that jewish is a
religion i know why is butters
on the desk but not better cameras come
here
butters come on come here come here
come here
yeah yeah likes me more good boy good
boy good boy always do what i say so um
all right well let's do it
uh let's get into it let's get into it
let's get involved okay what's your
chicken vault
hey what's going on chris sup matt
so seth here out of washington i'm 22
years old and for the past five years
i've been dealing with this condition on
my lips called exfoliative chilitis
can't tell right now but it's a cycle of
excessive peeling on the lips
it gets pretty bad
i've let it get in between me and
relationships and work in the past i'm
starting to come to terms with it now
since i have tried dermatologists all
their recommendations
no remedy solved it no steroids no
anti-fungal creams i even did a yeast
infection cycle treatment
that didn't fix it either and
i'm starting to come to terms with it i
still could use a little bit of help on
how to kind of
accept it more
be less ashamed of it
maybe you guys have something similar
but
i love you all i appreciate y'all
and i look forward to the day your dad's
on the podcast oh because
advice
man appreciate you buddy i appreciate
you buddy don't worry about your lips
worry about your ceiling it's super
weird so um well i think that uh get the
[ __ ] black phone mask have you seen
black phone i haven't seen it hooks
around his ears and it's like this
that would be scary though or scare
people out in the world well but
probably but at least at least they go
oh [ __ ] yeah oh you must be a big black
phone fan or oh oh my god you must be a
big ethan hawk fan but you won't be like
what's going on with his lips that's way
better right so either get that mask or
the [ __ ] huge one with the with the
dick nose on the
uh what's the tom cruise movement nicole
kidman
uh eyes wide shot yeah yeah yeah yeah oh
oh the black and white and get up and
get a big cape and walk around and bring
one of those boom boxes that just goes
why did you do uh gregorian chant like
it was like a twangy deliverance thing
no no no no but that's what the
gregorian chat is no gregorian channel
sounds like a growing chance not like
it's from deliverance but also
no way
but that's not what i'm doing that's
what it sounds like how i'm not doing
quick notes
with the huge difference
blocking his chapped lips
and then also turning people on you
might get a chick like that have we
talked i mean you're going to get so mad
but have we talked about what those
masters were really for to begin with
why they exist to keep people away from
you no
during the black death the plague the
bubonic plague when all the bodies would
pile up in the middle of town or in the
houses like one out of two people were
basically [ __ ] dying non-stop yeah
rotting flesh was everywhere the only
way people could get rid of the scent
was to wear masks like that and stuff
them full of like flowers and fruit so
that the scent from this big dick nose
thing could overpower the scent of all
the rotting flesh around them i know
that oh okay well why'd you let me tell
you
also so didn't [ __ ] know the look on
your face
that's not how people react
all of your knowledge is now based on
what happens in the tudors sam neil does
it dude sam neil said the tutor samuel's
in the beginning of it and he's the
[ __ ] uh the the um not the pope but
the way they call it the cardinal yeah
and he and he walks around with like a
handkerchief and he's just like when
he's all around the poor people and he's
just like yes yeah so we need to cross
we need to make these luck yes the
church and the state should not join yes
he says we need to do this it's separate
and i'm going to walk you talk to you
oh [ __ ] walkie-talkie
yes yes the church and the state has
happened we need to make this allah we
need to put those laws into effect you
know what i would do dude i wouldn't
have one of those big dick noses
with the high-ass collars
you keep the
you keep the [ __ ] scent coming from
you with the high callers and the and
the dick nose right and i wouldn't use
flowers i would have this like this
i would just be walking around like that
because coffee smells amazing okay but
it was oh it would overpower that you
had to like
try to just stick flowers in the nose
why don't they just i guess it wasn't
enough dude i don't know and breathe it
through the mouth
i mean it tasted bad probably it was so
overpowering apparently i mean dead
bodies everywhere rotting flesh
all over i don't think that we can
imagine what that might be like i think
they knew what they were doing i don't
think that was their first idea oh it
smells bad oh i got a good idea make a
thing that looks like i got a big dick
on my nose and stuff it with flowers and
fruit and rose water okay they go like
this oh man it smells so bad out here
they are are you thinking what i'm
thinking and they go like this dick nose
masks
ranking just moment on all people
and then some people nom nom and then
some people water
so many sounds dude
francisco
[Laughter]
but what about the guy dude what about
the guy get one of those masks get um i
mean for real though he said he's on his
way to coming into terms with it i think
whatever you're doing that is helping
you come to terms with it
keep doing that and then you will become
pimp and pimping and when you're pimpin
pip and everyone will not even notice
because your energy will be that
of someone at peace i mean pimp and
pimping right now so once you're at
peace
the energy off of you will counter
balance whatever you're worried about on
your face like if that's the thing now
like true when people here's the thing
when i was young i went to school with
um an albino kid
and
uh at first he was when we were really
young he was like real embarrassed of it
and it made it didn't make the kids make
fun of him and obviously it wasn't the
kid's fault that he got made fun of but
like it i think it exacerbated the issue
because once he kind of got a little
older
he started to get like
more bold about it yeah and then the
kids stopped
not only making fun of him but like it
almost like it seemed like he stopped
noticing that he was yeah yeah i'm the
albino guy deal with it right pretty
much yeah and so uh if you can get to
that kind of head space about your lips
i'm sure it's i'm sure it's not as bad
as you see when you yeah yeah yeah yeah
which is always how it is yeah yeah yeah
of course you got bad [ __ ] i mean when i
was younger i had really i had pretty
bad acne for like a year
and dude really i would always be like
[ __ ] everyone's gonna see this ah
and then i would talk about it like to
mom and mom would be like where where is
this yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah my
mother's blind but yeah so
um all right cool well that's good yeah
or you could just go get a sundan suntan
all the time and then be peeling all the
time and they want to get yourself
make it blend in yeah yeah all right
let's do it dude
next one
got a gun right here man chris
my question today has to do with
navigating sibling relationships in
adulthood so serious but i feel like you
guys are uniquely qualified to answer
um well i'm 30 my brother's two and a
half years older i'm definitely more
than that in this dynamic you know
meaning like i definitely have the
better singing voice he has uh three
sons so he's raising like three kids
he's got a lot going on
and um i'm well aware he like doesn't
have a lot of time and
like i don't want to
eat into like the little amount of time
he has yeah uh
but with that being said
um also very interested in maybe like
nurturing like
uh a newfound like relationship at this
point in our lives we aren't i wouldn't
describe our relationship as very close
but
um you know we're fellow travelers we
like
it's all love so
um yeah how does the how does the
relationship between youtube work like
how do you guys navigate that
and
um any suggestions would be great so
yeah thank you for taking my question
and thanks for the show
what why don't you show interest in his
family and like be like let's you know
what i mean like um auntie so and so
like let's all hang out their auntie
wants to see them you know oh auntie i
thought you're saying anti like
negative no no i'm anti-you i won't hang
out with you i'm anti-children auntie
auntie auntie auntie like yeah you know
i like twitter
um
yeah or yeah yeah exactly i mean she
says they're not super close so maybe
make more of an effort to try and be
spend time with him i mean look they are
your nieces and nephews right is that
what it is um so of course i mean just
yeah just basically of course i only
know brother sister mother father and
beyond that uncle ant and then beyond
that i kind of don't really know oh
niece or nephew then you're stupid but i
know if i think about it but like
brother bam i know that like if you're
like if you're like yeah if somebody's
like oh my niece and you're like so at
your mom you're you're and then who
cause it could also be somebody you
married this person or that or your
brother's you know what i mean yeah but
basically you're one of those kids
that's like oh i'm so good at addition
and subtraction but like multiplication
is hard like everyone's good at addition
and subtraction because yeah
it's so [ __ ] easy yeah i'm not good
at uh addition and subtraction oh okay
well then you're an even bigger idiot
than i realized so but it's all good i
think that um
i think that yeah
that's the thing well they said they're
not super close why don't you since he
has limited time try and include
yourself into things that he's doing in
the beginning because it sounds like
you're interested in i don't know if
he's interested in it or not but you are
their auntie and so why don't you try
and be like hey if you guys are going to
lunch or dinner i'd like to go with you
guys or whatever i'll take out i don't
know what your [ __ ] skriller
situation is but like you know what i
mean let's let's try and like build a
relationship this morning do they have
sports practices games they go to you
make a sign let me know what their
schedule is i would love to come and
like put in some quality time yeah take
them out on your own go you're my i
think niece and nephew maybe oh wow
doesn't know you know uh
but he's definitely my brother pizza
after the game right yeah there you go
roundtable pizza yup yup
um
yeah that's i think that's the way to do
it yeah yeah yeah yeah [ __ ] yeah dude
that was good advice i give good advice
okay well don't like you know this is
episode [ __ ] 21 already i know and i
often get so surprised when you give
good advice
okay
next one
hey chris and matt my name is jason i'm
27 currently a student at san francisco
state university um i'm on campus a lot
walking around and uh i get approached
by
a christian group who is trying to like
recruit me or something and keep asking
me someone still telling the bible study
and uh you know i've been polite to say
no thank you i'm not interested but uh
i've been kind of
wanting to respond in a funnier way and
maybe tell them that i'm i can't make it
because i'm
on my way to a blood sacrifice to
worship satan or just maybe just reply
hail satan and walk away right
you know but i don't know if that'd be
appropriate or polite you know
anyways i just want to know what you
guys would do would you continue trying
to be polite it happens like every time
i'm on campus and it's really awesome
um or would you you know respond with
some comedy and just do something that
makes makes you laugh they probably
wouldn't laugh they'd probably be
upset about it so it wouldn't be nice
but
it'd be funny
anyways just thought i'd throw that out
there appreciate you guys love the work
you do keep it up thanks what's up with
uh he goes to a like a religious school
is that what it is i don't think that's
what he said no oh then that's even more
annoying yeah they're just there i think
he's at a school because it's like prime
candidates young vulnerable people just
like cult yes but i think uh the thing
to do to save yourself time but also get
that sort of like
comedy thing that at least what
what being funny provides you can still
get the same thing if like say they
approach you and you know they're coming
you know what they're gonna say just
keep walking but as you keep walking
just say nope nope nope nope nope nope
it's a very mad thing to do yeah or be
like how about you don't be religious
you join my side right yeah hey here's a
no make pamphlets that's a good idea not
not religious this like you know what i
mean yeah like you make up your own
religion or you know the non-religion
here you go join my [ __ ] yeah yeah
make your own really join my [ __ ]
religion well but
well you're do
why because i'm already well okay so i'm
already okay so didn't say any nouns
we're both already didn't say any nouns
do you know what i mean but that's so
annoying i mean that's the most annoying
thing yeah
i'm glad you asked dude i've been
wanting to talk to you about the church
of guy who touches his hat too much
yeah that's who he was yeah would you
like a would you like a ball cap yeah
yeah you know how jews wear yarmulkes
brought it up twice maybe chris chris
and matt's grandma was jewish we don't
know because she was adopted brought up
three times
um
yeah i think you can look they're
approaching you about their religion
religion at least used to be one of the
most private things in the [ __ ] world
now people talk about their religion and
politics like it's their [ __ ]
favorite kind of juice or meal lunchtime
when did religion be when was it the
most private thing in the world though
because
two things you don't ask about was was
your religion and your politics when i
don't mean like [ __ ] 1400s because in
the 1400s this [ __ ] was really really
prevalent and everyone knew who everyone
was because everyone was one thing or
else you would be killed dead or you'd
either basically be wearing crosses or
have no head right so they'd be like oh
you've got a cross or you're catholic or
you're christian or oh that guy's got no
head so he must have been a jew or
something or something yeah yeah uh well
luckily we don't live then but no i mean
like in the 50s and before like right it
was impolite the 1950s i assume
you would get an answer when you asked
somebody what their [ __ ] religious
beliefs were and there's something to
that it's it's like
it's it seems so bold to be like to
expect other people to openly talk about
the religion or politics for that matter
yeah but you know i think you can so
they come up to you politely but what
they're doing is rude yeah so you can be
as rude as you want it doesn't matter
how like polite they come yeah the thing
it's like being nice when you're
stabbing someone you're still stabbing
them so when
[Laughter]
uh
but yeah be as rude as you want to meet
you and being rude to someone like that
is funny so you get a little bit of a
dummy double whammy um
oh here's another good one hey uh i'd
like to talk to you about it to try and
convert you to my religion oh
oh are we gonna [ __ ] whoa
that seems okay keep going oh we're
getting married oh my god okay are we
getting oh right dude right we're
getting married right and then they say
no you say then what the [ __ ] does my
religion have to do with you okay it's a
bit of a stretch but i still like what
you're doing spin around and then you
show them that spin move mentality
hoodie knew that was coming well we're
predictable but mostly it's it's good
that we have the spin move now
people can get the hoodie to have the
the words on their body backing up
that's right coinciding with the action
that's great
i never really realized that
baby oh my dude i'm very creative okay
all right let's go to the next one
what's up man chris this is brady coming
to you live from my stinky community
college in keller texas and i have
that theo vaughn hitter nice you know me
absolutely two years in the making i'm
really only one but
joked on us so i'm just a broke college
kid about to transfer over to texas tech
you know me uh and i just need some
advice on how to save money and not
necessarily spend it because a couple
weeks ago me my dad had a budget and we
made it
uh for like my cost to live there
including the house that i'm gonna get
and it's rounding 30 grand a year just
to live there for one year
and just looking at that number is just
bewildering to me
so
if y'all could give me any advice
be much appreciated
sore
yeah oh i gotta i gotta
get a [ __ ] job well yeah i mean like
well that's how people make money like
what do you mean how [ __ ] how do i make
money i don't know how to make 30 grand
a year what do i do get a [ __ ] job
yeah sign up for something well no that
doesn't do it you sign up for a job
softball you don't get you no i know but
i'm just you know being cute with it but
yeah yeah get a job sign up for
something i mean you can also is a job
i'm not recommending this at all but you
could become a criminal like a bank
robber no don't do that before you do
that i already said don't do it i'm just
saying you can do it before you do that
be a gigolo you can people make a lot of
money being a gigolo the old housewives
with that [ __ ] you know what i mean
the hair in the back with the housewives
just being like this or one of those
guys who you know what i mean dances and
they have the towel
like this and the party's like go go
what's happening behind the towel oh
secretly is like you could suck it if
you want you know right right right they
do that dude they got those porns
they've got those porns yeah i see those
points i've seen those porns too
remember a big sausage pizza you asked
me that the other day and i was like
what the [ __ ] are you talking about and
you still got a big sausage pizza bigger
of course i remember a big sausage pizza
they would put their
penis
so disgusting
how could somebody get hard from that
but who watches the fun porn who wants
it's the goofy porn the goofy porn like
who's watching the family guy you know
what i mean with the like with
lois with her tits out and [ __ ] i know
dude like but they they
the guy would come over and he'd be like
pizza and it was so obvious because the
pizza would be like this i'll like run
his waist and then she's like oh thanks
it was late though come let me get the
money and he's like and he opens it up
and then his [ __ ] penis is just out
of the center of the [ __ ] you know
big fat [ __ ] sausage ah just like
right in the middle outside of the
pepperoni pizza dude yeah and then she
would suck it yeah that's not how that
would go down
would be so smelly and cheesy dude
you know what you're eating the cheese
dick the [ __ ] rose water and omni
what it obviously should be is that you
open the box there's no pizza in it
it's disgusting to get like tomato sauce
on your j yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah you
just gotta click you just gotta yeah
just that [ __ ] tomato sauce on your
cockenstein know what's best though
don't do that at all and just have the
show up and [ __ ] oh interesting yeah
because interesting never i never wanted
the food thing with the sex
food was sex in general like nine and a
half weeks maybe the whole mickey wrote
yeah ken mason your thing was like
supposed to be so sexy and then i
watched it i was like he's [ __ ]
eating strawberries off her stomach what
the [ __ ] is this yeah so many sensations
sex stop eating yeah get a plate
have sex stop eating so fat you know you
know i mean just so disgusting just
don't like also too many sensations at
once right yeah yeah yeah um
yeah so this guy get a job dude
definitely 30 grand what he's saying
it's 30 grand a year to live
that's what he said that's so expensive
where he said he was in some podoc place
right where is he
if it's 12 months
that's divided by that's like two that's
not that i mean that's kind of how much
stuff costs
yeah i mean if you're in a city that
costs a lot like where we are [ __ ] costs
an outrageous amount that's about what
he was talking about but he said some
people somewhere in texas where was this
yeah true that's true texas texas that
shouldn't be that expensive it's not
where is texas tech is that if it's not
austin he's [ __ ] i don't think it's if
it is i mean i guess college towns are a
bit more expensive yeah
damn it's a lot of 30 grand a year to
live but get a job and then also do a
[ __ ] night hustle like what like
american gigolo or like gigolo yeah like
you know they're coming out with that
[ __ ] new remake american jokes
i love bernthal but like he's not
[ __ ] sexy
how why well that's a good point i mean
he's sexy in a way yeah in a way but
he's not like he ordered me if i was
gonna do it it would be a fantastic when
you order gigolo you want richer gear
that's right right
right
oops
yeah i could do it okay so you think
yeah you're right you're right it's like
he's too niche
he is sexy though to some women he's
very sexy he is an attractive guy don't
get me wrong yeah i actually really am a
huge fan of his yeah and i do think he's
handsome but a gigolo richard gear dude
i don't think so i get what you're
saying i don't know you're thinking more
of like a rupert everett would be that
even though he's like richard
butcher me no someone else like that you
know what i mean uh on that level
remember remember my friend who when we
saw we this was [ __ ] 20 years ago we
met this girl together and he was like
you could tell she was single and i was
like why and he said cause the way she
was talking to us or me or whatever
i'll never forget that dude and i was
driving and i go oh oh wow well that's
that's pretty incredible but in his
defense he looked
couldn't have looked more like tom
cruise he did look like tom cruise and
that's not like oh haha my friend looks
like so and so you got to see him this
was like
he looked exactly like he looked so much
like tom cruise like if there were
japanese tourists around they'd be like
and start taking pictures of them dude
yeah yeah
[Laughter]
[Applause]
[Laughter]
of all movies you know
of all
[Laughter]
all right next one
hiding yo chris matt
what's up boys hope you guys are doing
well directing traffic this is aggie in
san diego
and i'm calling for some advice on this
situation that i'm in so
i did this girl for like six years um
and i had a homie who was like my friend
for like 12 years oh
it's like one of those friends that like
in you know like at points you guys were
best friends and then you spread apart
and then
whatever
so whatever dated this girl for six
years we didn't work out i was toxic as
[ __ ] whatever
um
and then after
whatever we broke up they're now dating
uh um oh we know it
right
so and
i i'm asking for advice not on whether
or not it's right or wrong because
actually i don't care that they're
dating
oh
look at the girlfriend
oh look at the drone he's gone now i
believe i'm calling because um is it
wrong of me if i were to ever come
across this guy to slap the dog [ __ ] out
of him yeah i don't care he says hey
they're not like you can do whatever the
[ __ ] you want to you know who cares but
like i think there's a level of respect
that is betrayed when you do something
like that like
you know we're not we're not in the
[ __ ] we're not in 10th grade you know
like we're grown-ups we're not 10th
grade so you just like beat them up if
you do some grown-up [ __ ] that's uh
disrespectful
you get your [ __ ] slot for it you know
what i'm saying so yeah i don't know
what you think am i wrong for
slapping this dude if i come across
i mean this guy dude this is one of my
favorite ones we ever got just [ __ ]
last week a buddy of mine whose
girlfriend recently broke up with him
found out accidentally that
he him and his girlfriend were put
together for 15 years he was living
together they were living with a
roommate okay who was like the friend of
theirs
and he found out after she broke up with
him and didn't say anything about this
yeah that they were [ __ ] under his
nose in his house for like who knows up
to a year or whatever and now they're
gonna move in with each other
all the while the guy still lives with
the [ __ ] girl well the guy still
lives with my friend the woman moved out
but the guy still had his shoulder to
cry on and [ __ ] until the other day when
he found out
yeah dude just evil [ __ ]
but
that guy didn't beat up the guy so i
mean that's much worse than what this
guy's [ __ ] dealing with i mean dude
you just gotta let it you gotta let this
guy's like i don't care but should i
just you know look everything's cool i
don't care i'm fine i'm well past it
everything's cool i'm gonna be a bigger
person should i blow up this guy's house
with his family in it like you just knew
it was yeah yeah
guitar licks
just
just don't do that okay let it go it's
all good they both did you a [ __ ]
favor
and just [ __ ] you know also it's
after like they weren't cheating
yeah
right i mean it's still annoying if it
was his friend you know but don't worry
but you know you're one of
yeah then you're kind of being a [ __ ]
bro don't you don't beat someone up
don't beat somebody he's like you know
we're not in high school anymore if
you're not high school anymore then just
be an adult about it be like you know
what [ __ ] them and also what do you
think was going to happen you know what
i mean like that's what happened i've
said this
about i'll say this about everything
like this all the time the best way to
quote get back at someone for that [ __ ]
is to
not give a [ __ ] about it live and live
the best outwardly don't give a [ __ ]
about it and then soon after that
inward because you see the results of
outwardly not giving a [ __ ] about it you
will also on the inside not give a [ __ ]
about it yeah it's kind of like the fake
it till you make it thing
don't give a [ __ ] about it that is the
best [ __ ] revenge because then you're
telling them you guys don't [ __ ]
matter yeah i don't even give a [ __ ]
about you i don't even remember who are
you who is this [ __ ] person yeah yeah
oh he dated no he didn't i don't know
who you are also what if you lose the
fight right that's not good at all you
know what i mean then he took the girl
and you got your [ __ ] ass kicked you
just don't it's just there's too many
variables like also what if you get he
they [ __ ] calls the police that's the
big thing like what if you really [ __ ]
them up you get right like you don't
manslaughter dude
curb stomp them right i just think
there's too many things that could go
wrong plus
it's not a good look after that
you know 30 like a [ __ ] month six
months a year the as time goes on you're
gonna less and less like the fact that
you did that yes oh totally just a
hundred percent you're gonna be 60 and
you're gonna be talking to your kids
yeah like you know your father regrets
something yes exactly yeah i need to get
it off my chest i don't know why you'd
be morgan freeman when you grew up but
uh yeah that's cool all right next one
don't do it don't fight no fighting do
it no fighting hey guys i have an advice
question for you someone i guess who i
have an eight-year-old daughter and my
fiance is an amazing you know going to
be an amazing stepdad they get along
great and he's so good to her so my
fiance and i have talked about
if we should have a kid of our own
and the problem that i see with that is
that i'm about to turn 35.
so i worry that maybe i'm just a little
bit too old
and i don't know i mean i see women
doing it all the time now over 35 so am
i too old
or is it okay
to you know still try to have another
one because pregnancy gets a little
dicey after 35. so
yay or nay pregnancy
but it's not really after 35. it's not
really that you're not doing that you're
not 45. you're good honestly i was just
going to say this i have a really good
friend his sister
at 45 with no help of any kind of
outside thing she just got naturally
pregnant had a natural pregnancy and the
baby turned out fully [ __ ] healthy
with no [ __ ] complications 45 years
old that's 10 years older than this
woman i'm not saying every woman can do
that but dude 35 you're good that's just
at the very beginning of the time when
they say you really should start
thinking about hurrying up this process
yeah also what do you think your life
looks like in 10 years imagine that what
do you want and then also
right yeah also
you could try and let the let jesus
christ sort it out right i mean you know
what i mean that's the other thing you
don't need
i'll tell you what it was blurred let
them splurge let jesus christ figure it
out the fact that she's even asking
makes me think she doesn't want to
because it's such to me it's such an
obvious yeah give it a shot that it's
almost like if she's asked for advice
it's like no
i think she i said it though yeah but
it seems like she's actually
wants to be talked into it to me well
then she should and then take it take
our advice absolutely do it let him
splurge
let him split let the lord figure it out
dude yeah right you know what they say
let him support and let the lord figure
it out yep just be like huh
well constantly let jesus figure it out
constipated oh that's what did you go
like that could you agree
yeah oh
i had no idea
yeah i don't know so what you're just
giving thumbs up over there [ __ ] our
producer chris was like
and i'm like why'd you do that because
you agree he goes he literally goes i
wanted to move up yeah yeah yeah yeah
you want to move on dude this is the
[ __ ] questions you gave us
we spend time on it yeah all right so
okay he's got a hot one coming up yeah
yeah all right let's go next one hey man
show you chocolate hey chris my
girlfriend's mother recently had her
birthday i'm gonna walk away for this
one hey chris worst dude those gamer
chairs is he a [ __ ] fighter pilot but
no no no those gamer chairs that's a
[ __ ] chair you use to like do do
video games
if you're sitting at a computer hey guy
be
the dork you are yeah get a [ __ ]
chair that sucks put a folding chair out
there what do you it's like he ripped
that out of a lamborghini dude but isn't
that the dorkiest thing possible yeah
yeah yes but it's like i'll show these
guys okay i'll show these guys you know
this is actually from herakin
right
i don't know it's a huracan or whatever
the [ __ ] it's a lamborghini seat oh okay
all right let's do it dude he's got a
brixton shirt though
my girlfriend's mother recently had her
birthday and i wished her happy birthday
and
she uh she's clearly flattered but
she's asking if i could hang out with
her now i don't know if i should or not
i left her on red because i'm a savage
but
the door is not closed what should i do
do what hang up with his girlfriend's
mom yeah absolutely not
you like gamer chairs
oh he's hilarious are you out of your
[ __ ] you need advice on that [ __ ]
don't hang out with her wow you [ __ ]
idiot well it his girlfriend hey guy you
gotta ruin your relationship even
sending this video in yeah it was a bad
idea to do that dude what are you
talking about man hey guy you're young
so we'll let you slide yeah
but also he's like it's so he like he
was he literally was signed in on the
sign in playstation thing and then was
like hold on real quick yo dude lifeline
like the guy's priorities are there's
actually a guy in the room with him i
know fun of him for saying mother
he made fun of him for saying mother
instead of mom
wow he goes mother
wow like their beavers and butthead up
in there
chris
my girlfriend's mother recently had her
birthday and i wished her happy birthday
and
she uh she's clearly flattered but
she's asking if i could hang out with
her now i don't know if i should or not
i left her on red because i'm a savage
i'm sorry happy birthday thank you
wanna hang out should i do it or not
what the [ __ ] is that that's not how it
went down i left a re on red because i'm
a savage
not savage so savage dude
i mean dude this is he's leaving some
major [ __ ] out the set [ __ ] totally
was like happy birthday and then thank
you
do you want to hang out no definitely
said happy birthday you look great for
your age how what's your secret or some
[ __ ] yeah he's like oh wow okay that's
the savagery right there
yes savage left her on red because i'm a
savage probably respond to her later so
i won't be savage anymore but
i mean
i i dude i just this is a such a
this is your girlfriend yes if you love
her
don't do it also just don't do it it'll
make your life complicated this is your
girlfriend if you love her don't [ __ ]
her mom yeah you know that's that kind
of question
yeah
don't [ __ ] your girlfriend's mom that's
the 11th commandment
yeah
yeah moses left that one out when he was
yeah i was just like we don't they know
this he had the two uh tablets it was
actually three he just dropped one yeah
yeah like that that's a mel brooks movie
right yeah history of the world part one
no it's he goes like this he goes
i got 11 commandments and then they go
and then jesus christ says now we know
that last one nobody would be stupid
enough to do that
and he's like what about number 12 about
the gamer chairs and he says nobody
would be stupid enough to either those
take those off and that's who you are
dude yep that's who you are you're the
guy that moses
didn't think existed because you'd have
to be so [ __ ] that's 100 right dude
wow
all right are you good yeah all right
cool
what's up chris um and your brother or
whatever um wow my name is john i'm a
big fan
um of chris
um but uh my problem is i need to stop
drinking i think like i mean whenever
i'm drunk the right side of my like
abdomen hurts so i think my liver is
having issues
um but
i'm just such a better person when i'm
drunk like everybody likes me more girls
like me more i'm funnier i do stand up
and the best that i've ever done i was
blackout drunk
so i just feel like if i commit to a
fast life and drink you know more i'm
gonna have more success you know
career-wise and also just beautiful
women so
um
but if i you know stay sober then you
know be more mellow and like serious i
guess but i'll live longer i don't know
let me know what you guys think i've
tried switching my drugs up to give my
liver a break but nothing hits the same
as alcohol so
um yeah appreciate any advice and uh i'm
in la if you guys ever need an intern or
anything let me know yeah he sounds like
a good guy to happen
yeah dude i i couldn't tell if he was
joking i don't know if you're joking or
not but let's take it serious since you
actually asked uh you're
sounds like i'm no therapist but like
you're compartmentalizing and [ __ ] i
mean i was waiting for him to be like
yeah i mean i i don't know maybe he's
joking but that's kind of like he
put it this way he he's definitely not
joking about what's happening he does
probably do that
you know he does probably drink a lot
yeah but
your liver hurts right yeah but we don't
know if that is connected with the
drinking though i would t i would i
don't know eventually take a break see
what happens take a week break if your
liver stops hurting it's the [ __ ]
well just go to the doctor too yeah if
it persists i mean i [ __ ] know like
how i know but like uh it sounds like
you're uh
compartmentalizing man and like you're
making excuses to kind of keep feeding
your addiction uh and you uh
you're calling in here maybe for some
advice or maybe just to be silly but
either way honestly it sounds like it
might be a problem and of course your
best set was when you were drunk because
people were laughing that you were drunk
but that doesn't make you a good
comedian that makes you uh funny drunk
yeah which a lot of people are it's not
unique yeah yeah so it's way harder to
be a good comedian bro and if you really
want to be a comedian then clean that
[ __ ] up and work hard at being a
comedian um also get your [ __ ] in check
also if you do stand up and you are
great when you're blackout drunk what
are you gonna do get blackout drunk
every time you go up on stage well
that's what i'm saying about living fast
and [ __ ] but here's the other thing too
dude people romanticize that thing man
if you were to go back and ask everybody
who [ __ ] died at 40 or whatever uh
was that fast life worth it
they're dead so they can't answer but if
they could they'd say [ __ ] no man you
want to see your daughters grow up your
[ __ ] sons grow up you want to see
your your fam you you don't want to die
before your [ __ ] mom and dad this
sucks man like addiction's hard as [ __ ]
[ __ ] i'm actually
[Laughter]
just stop uh drinking too much and
stop
knowing it's hurting your liver
and then you can be better at everything
and not be wasted all the time because
no one likes i mean this guy's like
everybody loves me when i'm drunk i
guarantee you they don't yeah other guys
who enable you and are also drunk love
you when you're drunk and it's also
annoying man you're probably annoying
trust me yeah you're annoying when
you're drunk okay i used to drink all
the time i'm not even sober i just
stopped drinking because i i
but i believed i wasn't annoying i
believed that was the life of the party
but trust me i was annoying
[ __ ] yeah
i know that because i see drunk people
now and i'm like this [ __ ]
thinks he's the life of the party he is
instead of being the life of the party
the death of the party he is [ __ ]
annoying yeah you're like the guy that
brings out the guitar in the middle of
the [ __ ] party that everyone's having
fun at you're like okay i guess we're
gonna [ __ ] listen to some [ __ ] by
weezer now that isn't even good
like here's the other thing man like
coming from someone who absolutely has
an addiction problem
you gotta figure your life out man you
got to do it for you it's [ __ ] so
hard but you can do it um
i don't know i would suggest
getting a group of people that
are
willing to help or a 12-step program
um and it's not
easy it's [ __ ] hard
and if you want to do the work
then do both works try and be surprised
and so far and try and be a comedian and
also try and live your life true
um and not and not
drink and die and affect everyone around
you and now yeah not blackout drunk also
don't you want to remember some of your
[ __ ] life like if you're blackout
drunk just because you can make people
laugh in your life for the party and as
you say beautiful women like you more it
doesn't matter if you can't [ __ ]
remember it who are you doing this for
other people or you it's yeah that's
true it's also not what people like
you for trust me bro
i thought people liked me because i was
the guy who would come in and get all
the [ __ ] ladies and be cool and
i was charismatic and i was funny but
dude that's not why people like you man
like people like you because you're you
and you matter
and it took me a long time to figure
that out so
he was kind of being a piece of [ __ ] to
me in the beginning now so i don't think
people like him for him maybe he's
better when he maybe he's better when
he's drunk it's funny dude because i get
a lot of videos that call me matt's
brother so i think we're even yeah but
if you go look at the youtube comments
everyone's like wow matt and his brother
are amazing so thanks for that buddy
all right let's do the next one
how do you guys think you should spend
your late 20s
or early 30s oh i mean expanding
expanding it into your 40s
could be into your mid 50s what do you
think you should do with your life
that's around the zone where you need to
start settling in and [ __ ] honing in
on the things that you might want long
term when you're in your early or even
mid twenties not only is your brain
still actually developing our brains
don't stop developing until we're 25
which is pretty [ __ ] crazy mine's
still going man but it'll be so smart
it's not done forming until we're 25 so
not me take that apply that to your
actual life i think we can all feel free
to sort of like [ __ ] around and see
where we go until we're 25 maybe even to
our late 20s but around the late 20s and
certainly into your early 30s you want
to at least have
begun
developing that path that you feel like
you could be on for the rest of your
life or
realizing that the paths path or paths
that you've been on are not really for
you and try to move on from those and
try to find a new one but i think that
you know there are these people
you know my age mid to late 30s
that is mate both
is the fact
uh that are [ __ ] like
still spinning their wheels being
[ __ ] jackasses like the guy in the
previous video
and like they don't
they don't really have the direction in
their life
that and it's not like they're [ __ ]
up their life it's just like
i look at them a little differently than
i do or did people or my peers in their
early
to mid 20s because
by then you should kind of be figuring
your [ __ ] out a little bit more uh
and most people do but there are those
people that don't and i i think the key
is to avoid being one of those people
i'm not saying you gotta have everything
[ __ ] figured out yeah and you can
also change what you're gonna do yeah
exactly have some sort of a plan i think
is the main thing you have a plan that
you're on the path toward executing yeah
people change their [ __ ] when they're 45
and 50 and 55 and that's fine but have a
plan
and and take be taking action into it
you know um
that that's my advice but you know i i
don't you know i don't know how old you
are it sounds like you're i guess you're
probably in that late 20s yeah he looked
like he's the late 20s yeah um
so yeah
yeah he's also a crazy guy because the
way he began he's lurch so he's from the
adams family so that's good yeah all
right next one
i guess first of all frips a second my
question is for chris i'm going back to
perform after the pandemic i make
electronic music
and so
the question is if you have any advice
for
for
yeah for going back to perform live in
front of a crowd after such a long break
thank you man ciao nice and short let me
just before you answer nice and short
kept it concise kept the energy up got
specific enough but didn't get too
specific didn't carry on didn't [ __ ]
much go on and on and we loved it thank
you very much it was much shorter than
this um yeah so what you sh i well okay
so i'm assuming it was the pandemic
probably that why he stopped yeah
performing so only i'm only assuming
that because that's literally the words
he said oh did he say that yes yes uh
well dude first of all it's been done
i mean i know it's still going on but
like this is just how it's gonna be for
the rest of the [ __ ] however long
yeah like in the tutors there was a
place was
there's a stop talking about the [ __ ]
tudors but there was a plague that
lasted four different it had four
different swells and it took a few years
and it might be like the tudors but what
i'm saying for him is yeah
uh he's saying live venues like big
crowd big crowd [ __ ] for him haven't
really returned yet and they're starting
to
so he's talking about how did you make
that adjustment to starting to get back
into the swing of things with big crowds
and the energy and and just i think
everyone can relate even if they're not
performers like getting back into the
normal swing of things all in you got to
go all in 100
because here's the deal you can't
tippy-toe around covet and i'm not
[ __ ] i know i joke around about don't
push me but like if you want to be safe
and put a mask on and you're out in
public i think you should i don't think
you're a [ __ ] idiot for wearing a
mask do what makes you feel safe right
but no but some people do some people
like shame like oh you [ __ ] mask you
know i mean you know
yeah i guess i haven't really seen that
[ __ ] those people yeah yeah yeah if you
want to wear one wear one i don't give a
[ __ ] but like um although when people
have them on when they're in their cars
with nobody that's freaky that's weird
as [ __ ] and i talk about i have that a
joke about that kind of a thing in my
ass steal my [ __ ] but yeah um but yeah i
don't know dude i you gotta i think you
gotta go all in if you're if you're look
you're the dj you make electronic music
you're gonna like you're gonna do live
shows a mask isn't gonna you're gonna
get it or you're not so just go all in
and live life like you're gonna like you
did live life and if you get covered
you'll get over it you're a young
[ __ ] virile dude right you look like
elon gold and it's all good but what if
you did one of those things where you
know like some of those guys they're
anonymous they have big oh like [ __ ]
uh dj what's his name dead mouse yeah
yeah what is it not the dead mouse
deadmau5
and then the marshmallow yeah you get a
big thing on your head it's like it's
better than a mask
thick nose dj dude dude
check out this one
a lot of people just
getting killed
but he's not getting it no i know
because he's
ollie
dj dick knows dude we figured it out for
you we give you a whole [ __ ] career
pattern and we brought it back around
dude good you could also do if you don't
like dick nose because it's not like you
know it's kind of adult you could do
like dj black death because that's what
it was for ooh dj black death that's
cool dj black death do that dude yeah dj
black death with the big [ __ ] dick
nose mask they used to wear dude you
will die you will die you will die
you will die this is you will die you
will the whole side the whole sound you
and it will go you will die you will die
you will die you will die you will die
three minutes you will die you will die
you will die you will now you will die
and then
dick knows bouncing right right but also
the gregorian chants
but that's a while ago
that would be really cool actually we
just gave this guy
a lucrative career in fact the guy with
the video before what what should i do
in my late 20s early 30s yeah do that do
that too be to dj black death yeah and
war like be battling to the [ __ ] end
yeah bro this is awesome we're gonna dj
we just gave that guy such good advice
that goes for this guy and the previous
guy yep great cool all right what's next
so happy hey chris and matt um i've
actually been a fan of congratulations
since episode one wow day one baby over
here wow um so i actually have a little
dilemma so i actually did the horizontal
mambo with my
sister's friend with my sister um i met
her at my sister's wedding
um and she's currently in la and i'm
currently in uh new hampshire kind of
you know maybe 45 minutes outside of
boston
um and she's moving to boston next month
so i don't know whether i should pursue
things because i'm kind of seeing
another girl right now oh okay and
honestly i don't know how things are
going with this other girl um i'm kind
of stuck in a love triangle right now
and it's the backwards way just yeah i
want to know what you guys think about
this so backwards you should have just
started on with in the love triangle
[ __ ] a uh yeah yeah yeah hey guys i'm
in a love triangle i know which one you
should what you should do
whichever one you like more right also
the one that's closer
whichever one you like more is the one
you should pick out of the love triangle
and it's not awkward that it's your
sister's friend that's not weird at all
no yeah that's not weird at all yeah
your hair looks like a lunch lady thing
you have on it i do i am a lunch lady
um no yeah uh don't be do the one you
want to but also if it's between both of
them the one that's obviously closer
long-distance relationships suck dude uh
do that and then also it's not weird
that you slept with your sister's friend
i mean how many people in the world do
that so many you know uh as a matter of
fact dude
i know you'd be on me for this but in
the tutors they did that [ __ ] constantly
kidding me with the tudor's thing i'm on
up i'm on i'm on the fourth season do
you do anything else during the day
other than watch the tudors yep night
time i watched the tutors how many
episodes have i seen no like a per night
oh three
and for how many nights there's like
eight seasons of that show right now
four
wow i'm almost done how are you how are
you not done yet i'm almost done i i
watch it when i don't have something to
do if i don't have a show and then
sometimes i even come home and i watch
the tutors and they're just [ __ ]
everybody and cutting each other's heads
off but my point is
it's not good it's fine but
but
it's okay you did what you did
don't feel bad about it you know
you guys had horizontal mambo fires yeah
who cares if your sister's mad at you
have that conversation with her whoopsie
daisy sorry
but don't like feel too yes so i you
know okay i i didn't know you you would
people bother you that much or i [ __ ]
up or if there was a rule that you
shouldn't have then been like you know
what i'm sorry and then go for the other
girl but if there's not it's okay and
choose the one that you want to choose
and err on the side of whoever's closer
to you which is not your sister's friend
right right you didn't [ __ ] up that you
didn't even really [ __ ] up on it no you
didn't know you'll be fine
uh and uh
are you not in a lot you're not really
in a love triangle are you he kind of is
i mean it's a very loosely def i mean i
would wear like a pentagon well no it's
like it is because it's him and the two
women i understand but it's it's it's
like a little it's not like boom boom
they're all involved it's like certainly
wouldn't be a little love puddle it
wouldn't be like in a script it's not
dramatic enough you're in a love puddle
but it's uh yeah and twitter would look
at that script and you would be like not
for me and walk away love puddle that's
that's good that's a good term for it
yeah um but yeah
again anytime you're in a situation like
that
everybody's always like oh god what do i
do there's just two women there's these
two men i know what you do
you choose the one you like more yeah
but some i get sometimes do you like
people two people the same i don't know
if you like two people the same then
you're not in love with either one of
them oh
dude be dj go to take the one you love
and go to a dj black death concert yeah
that's definitely true but if you don't
know which one you like you don't really
like either one of them that much and
maybe what the [ __ ] is that and maybe
you don't like yourself
okay well that's totally a different
level
i guess that's always possible yeah so
that doesn't apply to what we're talking
about it could
yeah it could but so can you henry
anything you know um all right uh well
that's that's good that's a good episode
that's the other episode thank you for
for
uh sending the videos in and uh thank
you and if you have a question click the
link in the description below or go to
watchlifeline.com
and get your spin get you we have
different merches lifelinemerch.com
and when you get the pimp and pimpin
merch yeah you take pics tag me on your
stories i want to repost that [ __ ] we're
going to do a who wore it best lifeline
merch.com get the pimp and pimping gear
okay put it on your body take a pimp and
pick of you send it put it on pinpoint
instagram on your stories and tag me
okay
and also i'll be in atlanta and dc and
savannah and peoria and a bunch of
different places go to chrisley.com
stockton i'll be there so uh kristen.com
sounds pimpin pimpin everybody bye guys
[Music]